tanaka
towing the slab into boogie down tonight
you can see this will be his sixth start
on the year and in his career
at yankee stadium it'll be his 86th
2-2 swing and a miss
choi down on strikes one away as you
watch this slider i expect tanaka to
really use this slider if he has a good
one a lot tonight here is the one two
laos swings and misses two way
run it goes
that's popped up
urschela
toward the line and foul territory makes
the play and that'll do it
so here's lemayo he is five for 15 since
coming off the il it's the 01.
swung on and hit in the air to left
field and deep that ball is high it is
far it is gone
how do you like that for a beginning
david john makes long gone he homers in
the left field seats and the yankees
take an immediate one-nothing lead
and that is strike three taken
he goes for the fastball pops it into
short left
it's caught by margot you get into the
right spot it's going to fall right in
and cutting the mess to strike out
frazier
line right at lemay who fires the first
it's a double play
so bang bang boom boom a line drive to
le mayhew
and he made the quick flip the first
so first and second nobody out for the
inks but not much in between
ground ball
outing second loud or first with a tag
by choi good point
and a swing of the miss well you can
just strike him out to knock at a five
pitch second inning
and now he retires more goal on three
pitches
swing and a miss lau down on strikes for
the second time
tonight as lame would top the
leaderboard for batting average
he's going to try the other way as
meadows goes back he's on the track he's
at the wall see ya another home run for
lemayo this one the other way and it's
two nothing yankees
just an absolute clinic day in and day
out on how to hit last time up a change
up i'm out a little front i'll pull it a
fastball out over the plate i'll shoot
it the other way in a yankee stadium
and one more strikeout
and there's a shot into left field
deep and
caught in front of the wall
nearly made a bid but margot takes care
of all three fly balls the adamas is in
scoring position to lead off the fifth
there's kevin kiermeier
and he gets hold of this one that baby's
gonna ride out of here and up into the
second deck
kevin kiermeier has homer
in his third consecutive game and just
like that the rays have tied this one
swing and a miss
lao strikes out for the third time
against tanaka and is two
for his last 25
that one's hammered into right center
field long run for frasier and he makes
the play
a full body dive to the backhand side
and he hauls it in and took a double
away from wendell
that one's lined in the right center and
it gets past a diving kiermeyer and goes
all the way to the wall
boyd scores here comes frazier here's
the throw it's way high and moving to
third is yourself he's coming home the
throw home is
not in time
three runs on one swing and the yankees
lead five to two let's see if he showed
him that arm and then pulled it back he
snuck the other one in
looks like he did
that's some old school baseball dirt
flying catcher's out in front
great job by her sheldon to try to sneak
in
and there a drive deep into left and
that baby's gonna get out of here
home run on a 2-2 pitch and just like
that it's a two-run game
adamus hitting
his fifth home run of the year
third hit tonight and the new yankee
pitcher
is araldis chapman
look out there
101 up around the head
and uh bronzo can't be very pleased with
that well you know again
look i mean
i'll tell you if the rays don't do
something well you see this i mean it
becomes a matter of survival at some
point and this will now be a part of the
discussion for any other games these two
teams play this year after tomorrow and
now the
they are issuing the warnings to the
benches
swinging and a miss and that will do it
chapman does the stare rosso looks out
there as well
they have some things to say to the
yankee dugout
and now
the yankees are moving toward the rays
and this is not supposed to happen with
the social distancing rules that are in
place
and the umpires are trying to restore
order